ماليبو هي مدينة صغيرة
للأفضل وللأسوأ يعرف الجميع بعضهم
البعض ، إنه أمر سيء عندما تحاول
الذهاب وتناول فنجان من القهوة
وشعرك في كعكة ولا تريد أن
تصطدم بأي شخص تريده  دون أن تفشل في
الجري لمحاربة الأشخاص الذين تعرفهم ، ولكن
هذا أيضًا هو الشيء الجميل الذي يمثل
مجتمعًا صغيرًا حقًا ، حيث يعرف الجميع
بعضهم البعض بالنسبة لنا. ماليبو
بحد ذاتها هي بالفعل
وجهة دولية يعرفها العالم بأسره
ويريد قضاء إجازتها
[موسيقى]
هذا هو Surfrider Beach إذا كنت
راكب أمواج ، فأنت تسميه ماليبو ، النقطة الأولى ،
النقطة الثانية ، النقطة الثالثة ، النقطة الأولى
على بعد مسافة طويلة إذا كانت
كلاسيكية حيث تم ملء الرقم ، فقد
أصبح مزدحمًا الآن ولكنه كان
مجنونًا بنفس القدر  الستينيات ، أعني
أن الناس قد يظنون أنني أريده
كان ثريًا ، وهذا ليس صحيحًا ، فهناك مجتمع ضخم
من الطبقة الوسطى هنا حيث يوجد
للناس حدائق ، وكثير من الناس لديهم
دجاج ، أود أن أقول إن كل شخص لديه
دجاجة أو لوح تزلج على الماء
[مو  كذا]
[موسيقى
] الشيء الرائع جدًا
عندما قلت إن ماليبو تشعر بهذا الشعور
حيث لا يوجد الكثير من المباني
ولا يوجد الكثير من مراكز التسوق
ولكن عقلية الناس هي
عقلية مدينة كبيرة وهذا حقًا هو
مركز  يبدو أنه مرن عبر
خور منزل Adamson ، إنه
يشعر وكأنه تمامًا